all right hello everyone the three of us
are going to talk about video we have 25
minutes we decided to just play 25
minutes of a video on YouTube No
maybe 25 minutes in mathematica No
okay no we are actually working towards
having real video processing and
analysis in Mathematica but we are very
far from actually getting it we were
excited enough or we had enough at least
to share what we have come how far we
have come so far and what we have with
you this year and hopefully next year we
have a lot more to show and then maybe
release experimentally so this is as we
wrote here this is an experimental stage
and the goal is to be able to connect to
video files like we have been connecting
to many other file formats stream them
support a lot of formats I think we have
been supporting two or three video
formats with a very poor support for
elements and what can come in so
import/export is already a huge part of
this project that Peter is going to talk
about we obviously need to have a player
so that we see what is coming in from
the video file and how what we can do
with it maybe play whatever is happening
as far as processing and analysis and
then obviously the strength of
Mathematica should be utilizing all of
the processing and analysis capabilities
on the video files so for those of you
who came to my talk on Wednesday
better more no it is hundred fifty now
[Music]
we can go back so there are a lot of
video files around us are all of our
cell phones a lot of action cameras
GoPros security cameras from medical
procedures we get video streams
microscopes and a lot more devices that
are capturing the world around us into
videos and there are a lot of services
like YouTube and now twitch for sea life
CEO Inge and things like that there is a
lot of content that people would like to
analyse we were having some discussions
with the attendees wouldn't it be nice
to do either audio video or combination
processing to say what did I say with
person X five years ago at the tech
conference in Champaign and be able to
analyze that or or even find that and
there's so many files that we have
sitting in our hard drives and obviously
this we know we already see a lot of
applications for video and video
processing in the world of Medicine
material science security other industry
video games and the less just is very
long I'm not going to go on what we
think we can provide or would like to
provide is an extensive format support
and obviously a video object as I said
to be able to get a handle and see what
sort and then computations on separately
video separately on audio or the
combination and we are aiming for a very
strong processing and analysis support
kinds of the applications that we have
in mind or at least you know are very
easy to relate to or you have noisy
video you would like to stabilize it or
get rid of the noise and you would like
to track object find objects recognize
what's going on find people find
segments that are correlated maybe even
try to see if they're all UN really
video and who are correlated or try to
do analysis on the combination
reenactments and you know it would be
very nice if we could get I don't know
snippets or album of the year from all
the videos that we have so the goal is
big it's gonna take us a very long time
to accomplish probably something that is
very rich but we think we are the tool
that can achieve that so we are taking
steps towards that purochan you are
gonna show you details of where we are
at now and if we have time hopefully we
will we would like to hear any feedback
for what we should consider for the
first steps that maybe we haven't
thought about alright so let me start
from from import again this is we are
using prototype ear this is not
available in 12 and will not be
available in the released version of
12.0
so that's why we decided not to put that
notebook for you we're not sharing that
on book okay so we are considering in
the first release to add this for new
import export formats we think that they
are the most popular that we can support
so mp4 Matroska web WebM and it may be a
no TV so quickly let me show you what we
already have in our back-end basically
we are now working on the backend and
probably not it's not a surprise for for
most of you that we would be using
ffmpeg library as a as a back-end so
whatever you see right now it's based on
the ffmpeg so first of all we have a
quite a long list of available
containers so this is basically
equivalent to two to what we call
formats in import/export
however I mean there are many poor busts
that I'm not really popular or used even
though the epified back supports it so
this is I think you should be quite
happy with this for new formats well
supported and and you can you can start
using them hopefully soon
so they contain else and also we have a
notion of containers but in the
container you can store various data
using video audio and subtitle codecs so
let's start from the video decoders to
decode any video stored in a video file
you unit values decoders again we have a
list of various tech others for video
including the the one that are quite
standard not like h.264 or hopefully
will be supported on on all platforms
similarly for audio decoders again a
long list of various audio decoders
including mp3 mp4 and so on
and also we want to support subtitles
you can store subtitles in in your video
files they could be also stored in a
text file but now I'm talking about
their formats that can store it could be
stored directly in the video file so
these are the subtitle decoders alright
so let's start from metadata how can we
what kind of metadata we can import from
video files so I'm starting from opening
a video file I get a handout go to my
video and then I pass that render to
a red video properties function and
that's what I'm getting so encoder title
and color creation time location
approximate duration y approximate I
will always speak about this in a minute
then bitrate and and the next three are
the most important so first we see that
video tracks this video file contains
one video track and here we have a
properties like frame rate codec image
size language
similarly for audio tracks when you
click on that you have a channel count
sample rate codecs and so on and finally
this particular video file stores three
different subtitles alright so that that
was the reading the properties from
video files so I mentioned that
approximate duration basically to get
the accurate duration unfortunately this
is very expensive you have to decode
every single frame so for that not very
long file seven less than two minutes it
takes right now four seconds to decode
days but well only for the first time we
do caching so next time you decode it
it's it's immediate and so that's frame
count frame and duration are pretty much
the same the properties right so this is
again once one is computed the other one
is sketched and this is all immediate so
it's only a matter of it's an expressive
operation only for the first time
similarly we can read the duration of
the audio track and subtitle track video
data so that's that's the most
interesting part alright so I'm reading
the first 50 frames from that video file
and starting this in a manipulate
audio data again we can read the audio
and and store it in there in our audio
it does work we have multiple devices
devices and that's why we all right so
audio data then the subtitles you can
think about this as a first we I mean
we're we're reading as a header data so
that's more or less how the header data
for subtitles could look like and and
then the actual text a cup this is as
you can see it may be hard to parse it
it's a raw data bigger all right so
that's more or less what I want to say
about a import quickly about export and
I will let chain you to show you the
player so similarly as as as you saw the
decoders for for import we have also set
of available encoders for for so that
you can generate a video file using
these these encoders
seventy-eight here and corresponding
audio encoders and again subtitle
encoders so here in in this example I'm
showing how to generate the Matroska
video with video stream audio stream and
a subtitle stream so once once I
generate this file may take few more
seconds then we can we can read the
properties and they should be able to
see that it contains one video track one
audio track and one subtitle track so so
we already have the functionality of
reading all of these three properties
all of all the tracks start in the video
files quickly about transcoding we can
convert between video tracks efficiently
so that we're not loading all the data
into memory this is done by by ffmpeg
efficiently so we're just passing the
the handle to the video file we just
specified the output of the path to the
output file video codec video container
video codec audio codec and all
subtitles in this particular container
and people does not support some
embedded subtitles so so we don't
specify subtitles but that does work
energy it shows you this is that which
frame is that's how fast we can now
transport the frames in this video and
what once once this is done again you
can see that our output by the mp4 in
this case is contains the video track
audio track but no subtitles all right
so that's all I wanted to say about
import-export now to chain you to show
you how you can play the video in what
America no ok so motivations
I assume that's pretty obvious that you
only see where you get if you don't see
it you don't believe it so another
motivation was see this will come from
the decoder all the way up to the wrong
ends there's a lot of data to move
around so we have to make sure that it
works very well so functionality we have
multiple audio video track we can add
subtitle so for the multiple audio video
track those are usually useful or say if
you have different angles that would be
your different video track audio usually
people put commentary in one of the
track so that's that subtitle if your
foreign language speaker that's good
most of time video effects that's the
one where we shuffle in the filters in
between the input outputs so that you
can create different visual effects to
the stream so let's try this how do I
get next page up there we go so there we
go hopefully this works
our mission yeah I my application I
would like
there we go that you will see everything
is what it looks like right now we can
choose different track of the audio
group begin to realize here that here's
know in this case we only have one video
the trailer is not showing as a catcher
has to get rid of them in water and - we
do have insurance rolls - like the
machine would return to its former stage
and with all the minds to share so then
we also hooking a couple filters for now
so h2 tag you can see the movie in edge
detection follows do we have we have
Gaussian blur so yeah so it's a basic
standard video player with with visual
effects so what's next is more like this
is actually how we can hook up different
filters in the inputs which one command
shifts what's my shits well you're going
to see a lot of dynamic modules it's not
[Music]
yep yeah it's going to be some sort
bucks I'm sorry
well at this point is everything we play
right now once you play it's discard so
I mean Christus I mean there's a lot of
data to keep track so this what you see
in is most likely going to be the video
stream that we are going to have so I
can get this to work so I'm sitting on
my filter and I'm opening up a player
device and I say to play if you look at
image you see the image once you apply
the filter so in this case I'm swapping
the first in the second and fourth
quadrants so those are filters directly
in the ffmpeg filters and it shall parse
it and send it to the inputs so oh so
well let's try another filter so in this
case I was trying to talk vision we
actually have this in open alpha so what
you do is stock can only see two colors
the yellow and the blue and they don't
have a 20/20 vision so if I applied some
filters
Oh yep no oh there we go
if I apply the filter then this is for
your dog will see if you're watching a
movie
so all those filters are done on the on
a lower level with ffmpeg we can also
try better there we go
am i using the same stream yeah sure so
let's try this in this case I'm applying
directly on top of the frame that you'll
be seeing so I can basically it plus N
and I'm changing the ends so those are
basically the video stream that we'll be
trying to put it in where you can just
control it so that's basically what we
have for the players
[Applause]
yes right I read from import or in the
player you mean judge just yes I mean
right yes we may even get to the point
that you you may specify an import only
one channel of audio if that's what you
are looking for definitely you can get
the audio with all the channels yes we
support arbitrary number of channels you
the audio objects for audio formats as
well right yes
everything what is available you have a
fan pack just support it well I mean we
will be distributing the pack light
whether we create system functions with
we dysfunctional eat it up and more
right but you know you saw that there
are hundreds of different containers
which are hardly ever used so it is says
it's not really worth it probably to
create a new format from them but it's
all obviously available with the
available from the packet we have
hardware accelerators are available
through ffmpeg and and yes we will try
to to have them it's that the issue is
then that how do you get that
efficiently why so that your data is
decoded on GPU it should be go directly
to to the screen not back to the kernel
because you're losing a lot of
performance if you want to have your
data back to the kernel and then
transfer it using public to the
front-end so this this is a difficult
task if you have your decoder decoded a
video data on GPU don't through the GPU
dragger and then display directly to to
turn your monitor that definitely not
the first release of video
any other questions well not the last
one was actually if you see this is the
so that this dollar current frame is the
image current image that we decode and
we adding the floating-point number to
it so we just this this is top level
mathematic already it's not using but
this is simple operation that's why what
but that's ffmpeg takes care of that
lower-level backends for us we will work
it on a higher level already well it you
know that DirectX is again that you know
window specific we want to have the
cross-platform and right I guess the
handle to the video stream and then
processing is gonna be the same for
player
I'm guessing Bert we're gonna be having
an easier time on the cloud
I hope so I yeah I think really as I
started the talk we don't want to build
another player for me it makes sense to
rule out the import/export capabilities
before video comes out but it doesn't
make sense to release a video player
without having rich processing
capabilities or analysis capabilities so
I think encoders are going to be coming
very soon if not with the first release
of the video all right any suggestions
please let us know we got a wrap-up for
the next talk but we're gonna be outside
[Applause]